this is a production of cornell
university
thank you nate
the first thing i want to tell you is
it's very edifying to come to cornell
and if you're a young student you can
look up the word edifying but
but it means spiritually enlightening
and i like that's one of my favorite
words lots of things in life are
edifying
including coming here
right out of the gate i want to tell you
this is unique because i'm i'm honored
that bob langhans is with us
uh
he's come from way out of retirement to
be here
bob was real influential in my early
career i was never a student here but he
would
comment on the talks i gave and he was
inspired me to
attempt great things so bob i appreciate
that this was 40 years ago now that
we're we're doing that
and it says something about a department
when you have
emeritus faculty that are still part of
the department that that kind of
enterprise is bigger than any one person
so
of the many things i might have talked
about
i chose to talk about this title right
here
and this is mainly because this is
poorly understood
and
i want to help
shed a little light on this subject
i'm also inspired to talk about this
because another influential person in my
life
was lou albrecht and many years ago
he and i would compare notes i was
funded by nasa to which is growing
plants indoor agriculture on mars and
what's the
cost effectiveness of that and lou is
doing it here on earth and uh
he was another influential person in my
early career
so
i understand that this is the graduate
student
seminar
so i'm going to take the opportunity to
do a little more philosophy than i might
have and my very first picture
is of an artist
this is henry matisse the french artist
and he is famous
for this quote right here
i don't paint things i paint the
difference between things
and it was a number of years ago i read
this but it just hit me hard in science
we're always trying to do absolutes
and absolutes are very hard to do so we
do relatives
and
much of what we do says this is bigger
than that
now i'm going to tell you it's 12 bigger
but i'm not sure about the 12
it's just bigger
and
it helped me get a perspective on
what we can do in research and what we
can't do and much of what i'm going to
show you is
relative this is bigger than this this
is a difference between things and we do
the best we can to get absolutes
but that was uh a
influential quote in my life now
here's wheat in the field
i have been a active member of the
agronomy society for my whole career
in fact i've gone to more agronomy
meetings than i have at horticulture
meetings and
look at how people focus on agronomic
crops corn soybeans wheat just
exceptionally well studied hundreds of
people studying this
so
we can take the models
that we've used for wheat the many
models and wheat by the way is what
we've been funded by nasa early in my
career funded by nasa to study weak and
controlled environments and apply those
to now on earth
controlled environments and wheat
without sunlight so i want to
acknowledge two funding sources
i've been funded by nasa
pretty much continuously through a 40
year career and it's really been
helpful and
it's competitive proposals but i know
what their needs are and i'm able to
write proposals that have kept us
getting funded it's been a remarkable
thing for me
and now in recent years we've been
funded by usda and
neil here madsen is also funded by this
same group
we call this the lamp project lighting
approaches to maximize profits so this
doesn't say indoor egg it just says
electric lighting
so with this background i want to go
from
the field to indoors and look what we
can do
now
henry matisse painted pictures he didn't
put text he didn't put equations he
painted pictures
and the more i do this
the less i try to use less words
and less equations and more pictures and
the pictures can be and the graphics can
be memorable
and if there's one thing i think i'm
finally starting to get good at in this
point in my career is
more graphics and because they're
memorable i know it is because i've seen
my own students take graphics i made and
give talks 20 years later using the same
images if i were to put words and
pictures up they wouldn't remember them
so i'm going to try and show you
the physics of farming without sunlight
in graphics
we're going to start with 100 years ago
agriculture
pretty simple
we used a lot of animal agriculture
a small plot
the rain came in
and we got some yield now we vilify
animal agriculture now
because of the way it's done
in developed countries feedlots that is
real inefficient we try to get people to
change their diet
that's part of what my ted talk is about
is the ted talk is called
turning photon no it's turning water
into food
but it's it's an appeal to people that
change their diets to save the planet
but when third world countries do animal
agriculture it's really efficient they
feed the scraps the animals eat on land
that can't be used by people animal
agriculture is not bad it's just the way
it's practiced in the united states that
causes problems
so there it is
small yield rain fed now we fast forward
to today
the same single farmer grows a much
bigger plot of ground
the yield is much higher and by the way
all these arrows and these things are
scaled to inputs and outputs the size of
the arrows the size of the inputs
but now we rely way more on groundwater
and fossil fuels than we ever did
and
30 years ago we were being criticized
for fossil fuel agriculture
but fossil fuels are cheap that same
grower grows a big expanse of ground
especially in a place like utah we rely
heavily on irrigation
we use a lot of groundwater
lots of evidence we're going to run out
of water before we run out of fossil
fuels in fact
compelling evidence we're going to run
out of water for agriculture
so there it is today yield is bigger
same
person
now
if i told you the arrows are scaled to
inputs and outputs
the pixels in this green arrow are
bigger than the pixels in that black
arrow
the first law of thermodynamics says
energy in equals energy out
so how can this be
if we have this much energy in how can
we get that much energy out doesn't this
violate the first law of thermodynamics
no
because we forget about the elephant in
the room
kaboom
60 moles a day of solar radiation coming
into this this is a bright sunny day
and you know how crop production is
maybe
two or three percent efficient
well that's three percent of that
um
this becomes
insignificant when we think about the
massive input of solar energy
so we know
what the efficiency of leds are they're
astounding and we've got a bunch of
papers on
where they are where they're going to
get to
what if we wanted to
give a field
electric photons from leds
and we paid the electric bill what would
that cost to do that
it's a half a million dollars for hector
for 100-day growing season
and you think about the value of
agricultural land and you realize people
are buying sunlight they're buying a
surface area
with free photon input that's largely
determines the value of our agricultural
land
because the sun comes up for free
but this is 50 cents per meter squared
per day
and you think about a half a million
dollars per hectare
big big inputs that would be very
expensive to replace with electric
lights now this is full sunlight to
get this
so
if we take that out of there oh now put
this little sidebar in
i told you i wasn't going to show
equations but this is arithmetic
and i want to show you how we get this
because because it's really pretty easy
to calculate that number
this number right here is
the what we call the efficacy of
electric lights
now efficiency would be watts out and
watts in
but photosynthesis is not driven by
energy it's driven by photons so the
numerator has to be photons and the
input then comes out to be joules of
electric energy
and people that are in this business
know this number and
high pressure sodium lights which we
were the gold standard
in the recent past are 1.7 micro moles
per joule
and that's even with some advances
this number is double that
so it's just an astounding increase
in the efficiency of lighting
we're up to close to
70 80 percent efficient of leds now i
mean it's incredible
there's the efficiency
this is 10 cents a kilowatt hour it's a
standard price
a kilowatt hour is a really bizarre unit
there's power it watches power joules is
energy
a kilowatt is a joule per second a
kilojoule per second hours is time
the kilowatt hour is 3.6 megajoules when
you do the math
so we combine 3.6 megajoules of energy
for 10 cents
now the beauty of this is this is 10 to
the minus 6 and that's 10 to the plus 6
and that cancels and you got to multiply
3 by 3 divide by 10
120 moles of photons for a dollar
now this is very state of the art leds
but that's an amazing number to remember
not so long ago this was 100 moles per
dollar and in fact
this is a bit futuristic we're not here
yet
but that means a mole of photon costs a
penny
i should write that down on the board
somewhere
a penny per mole of photons
wow does that simplify the economics you
need 30 moles a day per meter squared
per day for your crop
that's 30 cents a day when you when you
run that number you can do a lot of math
in your head
so it comes to this
and now
if full sunlight bright sunny day 60
moles of photons per meter squared per
day
times this right here multiply two
numbers together
there's our numbers that i just showed
in that slide
that's where this comes from and
this is a little futuristic but that's
okay i mean i think we're gonna
be here in the in the next few years in
terms of the efficiency of lights but
it's still a lot of money for the
to buy photons
produced with an electric light
so
now we take the without sunlight part of
this talk
and we put a box around it this is the
exact same
thing
only with the box around it for indoors
now how do we make this balance
fossil fuels
for the electric lights
it's a massive input of electricity to
replace
sunlight
and when i do the math on this and i
start to calculate exactly the
efficiencies
this is a little
too big
to be a little smaller just because
electric lights are smaller and
we can get lower intensities but still
the size of this arrow is big
so how do we run
indoor agriculture
given this picture right here
well a huge part of it is
it's closed so we can elevate co2
and that's universally done
if you're gonna
enclose it that's one of the biggest
reasons to enclose it is so we can
elevate co2
and that is associated with about a
thirty percent yield increase
photo respiration and all the stuff you
tim said or was just in here teaching
this stuff a minute ago in this class
it's about a 30 yield increase but that
easily pays for the cost of co2
so cool and like i say
we're working on this for the whole
planet trying to get co2 up to make
agriculture more efficient in the field
but
so
now we get that added efficiency and
that's part of the reason this arrow can
be a bit smaller
but one of the
common claims in fact not common
universal claims about indoor
agriculture
is incredible water use efficiency you
see the claims
thousand times more water use efficient
than the field
so what's going on are these plants got
their stomates closed they're not
breathing you know how do they how do
they get this water use efficiency
dehumidification
plug in a dehumidifier
the transpiration rates almost the same
co2 closes still mate some
so it still goes to water vapor but we
don't let the water vapor escape and on
the earth it escapes and it blows back
to the ocean and gets mixed with salt
water
we trap the water vapor and condense it
and put it back in the crop
so when you think about this
the water in this thing almost could
come down to the water that's in the
produce itself
no added irrigation it's just recycled
and recycled
what a wonderful thing and if we're out
of water
this is going to make a lot of sense and
now you're going to say well
dr bugbee couldn't we just plug in a
dehumidifier in the field
yes we could but it takes a lot more
energy
when it's low humidity
to do that we but we could literally
take electric energy
condensed water vapor out of the air and
irrigator crops just not cost effective
in the field
but it will be cost effective here
when we run out of water
but
guess what it takes energy to run the
dehumidifier
boom now we get fossil fuels to
dehumidify the air
more energy input but if water is more
precious than energy
this makes sense that it might well come
to that
this arrow is smaller than this because
we can use heat pumps
um
and
it takes less energy to condense water
than it than it does to run the pure
electricity for the
lights
there's a lot of ways we can do this in
a cold climate you just just run cold
air through the pipes
so there's a model of where we're at
with conserving water and this is
something i wish
people promoting this would explain
there's nothing wrong with this
it's just that condensing the water
doesn't come for free it's
it's uh it's not like the plants
actually use less water
we just can capture it and put it back
on the plant
so now
i've
worked in this diagram a while
but i people say
well yeah you're big black arrows we'll
just use solar panels for those and it's
all good and now that's now the sun is
electricity
so i'd like to take a close look at this
can we use solar panels
to run this farm
so this is sunlight and here's our 60
moles a day a bright sunny day
this is the quantum flux from the sun
moles of photons
the energy flux the exact same sunlight
is 30 megajoules per day
just two different instruments one's
measuring energy and once measuring
photosynthetic photons
and on this side i'm going to show a
greenhouse and on this side i'm going to
show indoor farms
so we first take a greenhouse
and
a design goal for greenhouses is 70
transmission we don't always quite get
to that but we can with state of the art
70 times 60 we get 42 moles per meter
squared per day inside the greenhouse
how close can we get with electric
lights
solar photovoltaics the commercial
versions get up to 20
efficient i have them on my house they
start at 19
now they're down to 17
but
they're still we can get close to 20 so
that 30 turns into six megajoules of
electricity
per day
now we multiply
by the very best leds
3.5 that's what i showed in the other
slide
we're getting close to some purple leds
that are close to 3.5 micromoles per
joule
so this number the mega and the micro
cancel once again
and the product is 21.
so if we take the same sunlight
run it through solar panels run it
through leds
we get half
of the photon flux
per unit area of sunlight
and this is even a little bit futuristic
half
so what that means is
if we take two acres of solar panels
this is a picture off the internet and
it looks like really nice farmland
and they got solar panels on it i'm not
sure but
we can run one acre of leds at full
sunlight
this is not a really favorable ratio
but it does make the point when people
make skyscrapers with you know 30 levels
and then the solar panels are on the
roof
oh
right
those solar panels are going to provide
sunlight it's not going to happen
but when you think about this
this is full sunlight
and this is now
now i'd like to take a look at the
potential of this not just what we have
now but what it could be
same same diagram
greenhouse is the same
now maybe it will get better coverings
maybe this number will go up but for now
let's keep the greenhouse the same
now solar panels 30
efficient those solar panels that nasa
launches on satellites those are about
30 in the low 30s for percent efficiency
those are super expensive panels
um
let me do another little sidebar
this is a really interesting number i
have a lecture on
efficiency of photosynthesis and the
efficiency of solar photovoltaics
both processes follow what's called the
stark einstein law
which says
one photon excites one electron
and i love being able to quote something
from einstein that i can understand one
to one
so one
photon from sunlight excites one
electron in a solar panel and that's the
first step in photosynthesis two
photosynthesis in theory can get to
thirty percent deficient and in practice
we get into the mid twenties percent
deficient
but why is
photovoltaics better than solar panels
here's the reason
here's wavelength this is sunlight
with solar panels we can layer panels
and if this was plants we'd roughly be
using this blue region down here
and after
700 750 nanometers the photons are too
low energy we can't use them but we have
solar panel coatings that can capture
lower energy photons out here and you
add the colors together and you get it
beats photosynthesis
because they can use lower energy
photons in a solar panel
all right
30 efficient now we're up to nine
now we run these through leds
the theoretical maximum efficiency of
solar panels is about
five
micromoles per joule
uses planck's equation inversely
proportional to wavelength
but
i don't think we're ever going to get
100 efficiency of leds but i think we'll
get to 90 percent efficient
so we're close now
39 times 4.9 we're equal
now one acre of solar panels
gives us one acre of full sunlight with
electric energy
and yeah i don't know how long it's
going to take us to get there but we're
headed in this direction now here's
another key thing
what if this is a cloudy day
well everything scales the energy goes
down this goes down it's still a
one-to-one ratio
but if you're in plant science do we
grow
lettuce indoors under full sunlight
no we do not
500 micromoles is plenty to grow lettuce
and that's a quarter of full sunlight
so with electricity we can take this
light and spread it out over more acres
so now we have more acres of indoor
production and we have acres of solar
panels
but
we can't store
electricity
or at least we don't have efficient ways
to store electricity
so if the sun is if it's a dark day you
want to concentrate this if it's a sunny
day you can spread it out every day is
different
but here's the key point
even though we don't have cost effective
ways to store energy for the long term
there's a lot of options to store it for
a period of hours
not days and weeks like an electric car
but
run a pump pump water uphill and and
then at night the water runs down he'll
do hydroelectrics a lot of things we do
to store energy
for short periods of time
so now we can take those peak sunny days
store the electricity for a few hours
and have a 16 hour photo period year
around
with a low level of light
so that's a very key part of indoor
agriculture is distributing these
photons in time to make the system
maximally
efficient right now we just buy
electricity off the grid
but if we're going to look at something
sustainable we can't do that we've got
to do it with solar panels
so
this is where i can and we have a smart
board for recording and i could put
black slides and do calculations on the
board but that would ruin this screen if
we did that
and i'm going to switch
to
calculating yield
potential yield
in a controlled environment because this
is key to the whole thing
how high can
you get and i see people all the time
saying we have no idea how high yield
can eat what do you mean we know the
efficiency of photosynthesis we can
calculate that
you should quit saying we have no idea
i have this is one of the papers very
early in my career and if you're a
really old geezer you remember frank
salisbury's plant physiology textbook
um he he's one of the reasons i went to
utah
to work with him as a young scientist
exploring the limits of crop
productivity 1988
published in the journal plant
physiology
and it was this four component model
that helps us calculate
potential yield
the first so we start with moles of
photons in and you just take a one up
here
we assume in this case 80
capture of light
now when a crop is filled in it's
probably 95 capture of light but it
always takes a while to get there and
you have to average in the low capture
in the beginning with the high
this is a very high number but lettuce
can get their high density lettuce 80
percent capture photons if photons hit
the ground or wasted
then we the next step
is
quantum yield
moles of carbon fixed per mole of
photons
and this is a less well-known number but
with co2 enrichment
we can get to 0.6 now this is heavily
dependent on light intensity the higher
light the lower this number
but for low light lettuce 0.06 that's a
very excellent number
for perfect lettuce no
no problems anywhere
then we have to multiply that by
respiration efficiency of the plant
you know we sort of go two steps forward
in the day and one step back at night as
the plant synthesizes proteins and other
things and this is now a well-studied
number
and 60 efficiency in respiration is the
widely used number
and this is successive multiplication
0.8 times 0.06 times 0.6
harvest index is the
edible part divided by the total and in
the case of lettuce
90 i mean it's incredible just a tiny
bit of stem base and roots
this is this is
why lettuce is so good you multiply
those four together
we get moles of carbon fixed per mole of
photons
and then we can multiply by the ratio of
weight of the plant by carbon
that's 30 grams per mole
0.07 grams per mole
that's another really really useful
number
but it's hard to remember 0.07 i like to
remember numbers that are more like one
like
a penny per mole of photons
so let's put in potential
what we think we could get the 80 goes
to 90 with variable spacing
maybe a little lower light this inches
up
we do cool nights to preserve carbon 65
harvest index
now we get to one
so this number
is what i've used in lots of models
to say potential yield if everything's
just right and it only works with
lettuce
or leafy greens because of this super
high harvest index
many of you may know our field crops
just indexes are more like forty percent
and with plant breeding or forty five
percent you're way or half of this
number
um but with lettuce we can get to one
so
now let's we can do some
economic analysis with this because
we're going to say
we can produce a gram of dry weight
for molar photons
and the photons cost a penny per mole
so let's take a look at that
this is a paper with some colleagues
we sent this to science they said no
we're not interested but nature took the
paper
and
that's pretty common to get them to even
take a paper for review
photons for physiology and food
this is the cost of the electricity
divided by the value of the crop and
micro greens and lettuce this is like a
no-brainer
the electricity one to five percent
micro greens are a lot better than
lettuce
because they're real high water real
high harvest index real high photon
capture but both of these are really
favorable
because the photons didn't cost that
much now
let's do tomatoes
now tomatoes
have a much lower harvest index there's
a lot of stems and leaves we throw them
away
tomatoes are also less water this is
assuming
95
percent water
because that's what we sell is fresh
weight
tomatoes are less water lower harvest
index
that number jumps to 18 percent
so suddenly tomatoes are four times as
hard to do
as lettuce
but
depending on the other costs in the
system 18 still okay we the value of the
product justifies the
electric bill
now let's keep going and you're doing
strawberry research here um
in this paper i calculated this for
other vegetables like broccoli
these are things with lower harvest
index and higher percent dry weight so
they're harder
to do economically
and i just put general vegetables 103
percent
so just the cost of electricity
at current value of electricity and the
market value of the product
you could sell them and pay the electric
bill but no other costs you couldn't pay
air conditioning you couldn't pay labor
nothing just
they're equal to the cost of the
electricity to grow them the point here
is it gets rapidly harder
to
grow lower value
higher dry weight crops
with electric flights
so if that's the case
some people say field agriculture is
dead
we're going to grow wheat and rice
in here
now wheat and rice are real low value
and real high dry weight
100 times
the cost of the electricity
just to run the lights is a hundred
times more than the value of those crops
unless we are really really out of water
we are not going to be growing
wheat and rice
with electric lights the economics are
not even close to uh
favorable
it doesn't keep people from promoting it
and trying um and and i'll say in a
minute it depends on some other factors
too
so why is this so big
market price
it goes from high to low and then the
other big factor is harvest index
really high harvest index down to
well
i showed this slide in bargaining
university there's a couple years ago
right before covet or a slide like this
and i don't know if you know leo
marcellus he's one of their
long-standing researchers and he jumps
up and he says ah i can get 70 and i can
get tomatoes better 90 water and you
know okay
that
but that means this is maybe more like
10
or something it's still hard to grow
tomatoes
so now let's look at this another way
well before i get there
how about shipping
i was motivated to do an analysis of
shipping costs because
man a big truck driving from southern
california
to manhattan or to ithaca
wow that just has to be a massive amount
of energy
this cannot be cost effective to ship it
across the country
so we do some arithmetic and i had a
call up shipping companies and get data
those big trucks only get seven miles to
the gallon
and
diesel fuel is 139 000 kilojoules per
gallon
2 800 miles diagonally across the
country you multiply those numbers
together
oh and the trucks can hold 18 000
kilograms of fresh waste a big truck you
multiply those four numbers together the
units cancel
three kilojoules
per gram fresh weight
wow
that is a lot of energy
to
ship it across the country
from
in this is a refrigerator truck by the
way so it's even more that's why the
mileage is so bad
so how much does it cost for the
electricity to grow
a grand fresh mass of lettuce
same math as before
only now
one mole of photons 20 grams fresh this
is five percent dry fresh
five percent dry weight
our very best electric lights
14.
the cost of the the energy cost of the
electricity
is about
four to five times greater
than the shipping cost
this is not an intuitive
thing at all but
i've shown this math to several people
and they say no it's right and then
turns out
mother jones magazine
did an article on this some years ago
hey you know that magazine was still
around but they're thriving
and their article was called house of
chards
and they had my calculations in there on
shipping
and it's
indoor agriculture is a wonderful thing
but
don't tell me it's going to save the
planet
if it'll save the planet if we can get
people eating more fresh fruits and
vegetables that's a great thing it's
they're wonderful and that's a huge
thing and it'll save the planet if we're
out of water
but we're not going to get there on an
energy basis that's a staggering
difference
with the cost of shipping
now
this slide
was inspired if you read the fine print
look at the authors on this
david de villiers
we read lou albrecht 2011
energy use and yields in tomato
production
field high tunnel and greenhouse
compared to the northern tier of the usa
this is a great
paper now 10 years old
and i took the numbers from this
paper and adapted them to make this
graphic and
there's the wallbreak
who uh
i understand is as sharp as ever just in
assisted care living
but he inspired me early to do this
stuff so let's take a look at this
grown and chip this these are kilo
kilograms co2 equivalent per kilogram of
tomatoes
transport point three to bucktion so the
sum of these two is 0.6
kilogram equivalents hoop houses wow
they're wonderful now only in season but
there's no shipping
they're wonderfully efficient right to
the consumer
heated greenhouse
the heating's a big penalty
and the production costs are a little
bit higher because very intensive
fertilization and and watering and care
but now look at indoor farming
the electricity cost is big
now this is kilogram co2 equivalence for
this
um
so you add these numbers together to
get the comparison for tomatoes
what about lettuce
this was inspired by mike hamm a
professor at michigan state this is a
paper he wrote on a similar thing
transport is more for lettuce doesn't
ship as well you got to ship it faster
refrigerated
hoop house are still very efficient
heated greenhouse the story is similar
um we just have to add in the
electricity for uh
lettuce now
this is not cost this is not the
economics
this is kilograms of co2 equivalence and
if we're interested in
reducing our carbon footprint this is
what matters
we got to find a way to get this number
small with solar panels to make this
this
system work
but it does say wow really simple things
like hoop houses are wonderfully
efficient
um except for labor
to do all this work in a hoop house
one more slide on
economics
if we take
the same numbers we did before
cost of electricity efficiency of the
lights multiply them together
when we get 0.5 grams per mole from our
yield model
we can grow
a kilogram
of dry weight of food
for 24 dollars of electricity with just
the electricity not anything else
so now let's look
at the value of the products
starting with wheat
organic wheat high value
wheat's about four dollars a bushel but
organic wheat's nine
that comes out to 32 cents per kilogram
of wheat
this number is a lot bigger than this
number
it's unless something else becomes
radically limiting it doesn't make sense
to do wheat
how about tomatoes
this is a
high-priced kind of organic high-value
tomatoes
they're 90 percent water that's huge
100 a kilogram that number is bigger
than that
so now if the long as it's a high value
crop and we can sell the water
for fresh produce makes sense and
tomatoes are even better
95 water
so these two numbers exceed that but it
it helps to
show the challenges of different crops
in indoor agriculture
some of them make immediate economic
sense and others are very
challenging
aerofarms who's been working on growing
strawberries
and i'm thinking oh you know how hard
strawberries are to grow i mean way
harder than lettuce not just the crop
itself but the economics
and i
well they're not there yet
strawberries are tough
i'm going to close
yeah how many about five or six minutes
okay that's why i said i'm going to
close i'm watching the clock
um
i did just a couple two slides left
i've done a bunch of analysis
which i'm not going to show you but it's
pretty simple
in a greenhouse you pay for the heat
and the lights free
and so what's the ratio of joules of
energy per heat to photons of light this
we can call this one micro moles per
joule
that we're getting in a greenhouse and
over here
the heat is free and we pay for the
electricity three micromoles per joule
so how does this compare
not surprisingly
here's light through a season this
happens to be in logan utah but get
similar things here dark in the winter
here's an average
in these dark months indoor farming
clearly works because
the electricity is cheaper than the sun
here it doesn't
and i went through a bunch of
calculations to see when it's cost
effective and then
i had an opportunity to meet this young
scientist luke grahams at wageningen
and
he published this paper plant factories
versus greenhouse
comparison of resource use efficiency
and to make a long story short he said
this is a no-brainer
in these polar regions indoor farming
always wins
and then the middle latitudes it doesn't
win now if you're interested in this i'd
recommend his paper because it's full of
equations and the details and
the resources for this
one of the things he does is water in
that paper and these blue dots are where
indoor agriculture makes sense because
we're out of water
and it could be very efficient for water
so water and energy are the
two
two big
factors
i'll close on one slide
the biggest advantage of indoor egg to
me
is it can be very automated
shelves of plants
the labor bill goes way down and we're
having trouble getting labor for
agriculture
the biggest disadvantage is electricity
so now it works because this cost goes
down and this cost goes up and we can
we're at least on the threshold of doing
this economically for sure for lettuce
and
microgreens
but it's going to be a while before we
get there with uh
some of the other crops even crops like
broccoli is just much harder
so i'm going to stop there and
take questions
we don't have anything from geneva at
the moment anybody any questions here
can you go back to the um
electricity
this one right here no the economics
yeah right there i'm just curious what
that 24 is for that factory this one
right here
no this is just the cost of electricity
well
this is the cost of electricity right
here for molar photons
this is from the yield model
and
now i just said lettuce we could get 0.7
so
but this is for
dry weight not fresh weight okay and
this is a more
this would be a very high yield for
field crops
field crops we get to
0.3 maybe grams per mole this is a high
estimate for yield
so i've kind of
it's at least 24 per kilogram and maybe
more like 50
but i wanted to make this number as
small as possible so people couldn't say
i was rounding the numbers in my favor
but that's where it comes from cost of
electricity times yield
per photon
any settings
or
it's for anything
yes has anybody done these calculations
calorie produced because lettuce and
tomatoes
hold dressing but
yeah
i'm sure they have
and
all of us in horticulture look really
pretty bad when we do calories because
we got homology which
you know apples and oranges and
um
agronomy their their favorite motto in
agronomy is agronomy feeds the world
right and yeah well horticulture makes
the world healthy
because but
none of this looks very good for
calories
you have to have
wheat and rice are the two staple crops
in the world
they're similar in terms of human
consumption
and oh my i think something like 80 of
the world calories comes from either
weed or rice
yeah so those are those if you got it
you got to do those to feed the world
corn and soybeans are fed to pigs
almost always at least now in the
commercial approach
yes um
have not
um
but we could
i'm sorry what was the question again oh
could could we do this with wind energy
um
and
it's similar to challenges
i mean when energy is so localized you
know when
you fly across the country and you can
see a bunch of windmills nothing
wind energy is more challenging than
solar because it's so non uniformly
distributed a few places with high wind
and we're tr and we're working hard to
mine those places
um where solar is what's what's the
number
more solar energy falls on the planet in
an hour than the whole population uses
in a year
i mean we have abundant solar energy
um we just got to figure out how to
use it
so the reason i didn't do wind is
because it's less available and it's
generally less favorable economics
but in the places with high wind then it
works
yes
along those lines so i'll keep it i'll
push it a little bit further what about
nuclear or then like nuclear fusion sure
and and if we could get nuclear fusion
wow
now this whole thing makes sense
immediately
but if we got nuclear fusions all kinds
of things would change
um
gas-powered cars would go become
old-fashioned overnight
um
so
that depends so when you think about big
picture energy depends on how how we can
get electricity
um so what exactly are the benefits
outside of reduced labor costs of
automation like are there
benefits other than like economic
reasons for reduced labor costs
are there are there benefits other than
reduced labor right so
is like the main um
no high quality food is a huge benefit
very fresh honestly i think we
we would get people eating more
vegetables if they were high enough
quality but right now you go to the
store and only the wealthy people can
afford those and the people that need
them the most are the
underserved people and we're not going
to get to those people when it's
four dollars per pound of lettuce or
tomatoes
um
they're buying the cheapest stuff they
can
get
but that's a that's a huge benefit to uh
to higher quality produce okay but
like one thing of inverac is like you
said increased automation right that
wasn't the last slide
is there like
that is like a benefit because it
reduces the labor costs
but
is there any other benefit well
um
yes
as i mentioned savings of water that's
for sure
we can also say savings of fertilizer
because if we do it right we can recycle
the fertilizer too doesn't go into the
ground water
we're going to run out of phosphorus at
some point
and so this
a system like this can be more
fertilizer efficient
because it's very controlled
yes
yes it lends itself to a lot of
technology
i mean let me i'm super excited about it
because that's what we do you know
controlled environment agriculture high
input high output
um
but it's i guess the point is it's got
farther to go than most people like to
admit
for um
low lower value crops
okay well let's thank dr buckley
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu